the following video contains spoilers
for crimson peak infinity war doctor who
return of the jedi a new hope mad max
fury road guardians of the galaxy vol 2
stranger things war for the planet of
the apes avatar the last airbender game
of thrones infinity train shirat and the
princesses of power and dante's peak
for some reason
some people are just never appreciated
in their own lifetime
[Music]
hello folks today we're gonna go over
some tropes specifically one trope the
death equals redemption trope i don't
have any particular impetus for talking
about this well i mean other than having
wanted to tackle it for a little while
and realizing that if i don't jump on it
overly sarcastic productions we'll cover
it in a trope talk and probably make
every point i'm about to and also do it
better than me professional jealousy is
a hell of a motivator sometimes but
let us get right into this
[Music]
so what is this trope well it's when a
villainous or severely morally
compromised character does a heel face
turn and assists the good guys in some
way maybe they try to sabotage an evil
plan that's already in motion maybe
they're a minion who attacks the big bad
evil guy outright maybe they jump in
front of a bullet meant for the heroes
their reasons for this can vary actually
quite wildly everything from realizing
the scope of the damage of what they're
doing for really the first time finally
admitting to themselves just how far
gone their evil boss really is or maybe
they've got some reason to be soft on
the heroes
but the important part of the trope is
that through this positive act the
character dies either immediately or
soon after as a direct result of their
actions
don't worry we're going to get into
plenty examples of this as we go along
[Music]
first let's talk about why this is even
a trope in the first place because there
are reasons these ideas get used so
often so there's a few factors on why a
writer director creator whoever might
decide to redeem a character through
death
firstly the writer might feel that for
the crimes the character committed up to
this point there's just no other way to
even attempt redemption they've done too
much damage to be let off the hook and
allowed to live so you establish that
there is some good in them and then kill
them off in the same stroke so it still
feels like justice was done
in a more long-form story like a tv
series or an ongoing novel series the
writers may not want to figure out how
to integrate a redeemed villain into the
hero party or otherwise just don't feel
like using them once they've changed
sides this one actually kind of points
to the bluntest reason why this trope
gets used
the redeem character has lost a lot of
their narrative purpose at this point
you see if a character's role in the
story is largely building up to the
point that they change sides
then the instant they do that their
personal arc is complete and anyone who
either doesn't have an arc or has a
completed arc is frankly easier to kill
off because the audience won't be left
feeling like they died before their
story was done
so since their arc is finished anyway
there's no harm in just clearing them
off the board at the same time
now to be clear this trope by no means
says that death is required for
redemption and as noted it usually has a
lot to do with the severity of the
previous offenses in return of the jedi
darth vader's redemption is to save his
son and die in the process because
well because he's darth freaking vader
and even before the prequels came along
and revealed him to be a child killer
he's just done too much he's too much of
a bad guy to be allowed to live
but just as a point of comparison in the
original star wars film a new hope han
solo is also
redeemed but he's redeemed through
something as minor as just helping out
during the death star trench run
that's because han
isn't a fundamentally bad guy he's a
selfish guy he's certainly a bit morally
grayer than luke or leia but his
supposed offenses are minor so he
doesn't need to do as much to be
redeemed it's not necessary to kill him
[Music]
so with the basics covered let's dig
into how this actually plays out in
practice now from my way of looking at
this it comes in three main flavors the
first is the character does the right
thing and switches sides but doesn't
realize that what they're about to do is
going to cost them their life think
thomas sharp in crimson peak all he's
trying to do is stop the cycle of
killing that he and his sister-lover
have been in for years and he clearly
doesn't realize that this break is going
to drive lucille to stab him directly in
the face ah
sticking with tommy hiddleston loki's
death in infinity war also fits this
even though he'd kind of been redeemed
prior to this but the reason it fits is
because he clearly thought that he had
the drop on thanos and he was just wrong
about that he didn't think he was going
to die missy and doctor who is another
good example though a little grayer
because it's possible that she knew that
going to help the doctor would get her
killed tiny whiminess and all that but
there's also no real direct evidence
that she thought this would happen she
doesn't seem surprised when it does but
she does the right thing and unwittingly
sets off her own death
that's option one on the other side of
the spectrum there's the willing
sacrifice where the character in
question is
fully aware that what they're about to
do is going to get them killed and they
do it anyway
this is an easy way to really jack up
the power of the heel face term because
it's not just doing the right thing
it's doing the right thing
and willingly paying the ultimate price
and this one shows up all over the place
from knucks in mad max fury road to doc
ock and spider-man 2 to billy and
stranger things season 3 they all knew
that they were going to do something
that they wouldn't survive and
they did it anyway now a willing
sacrifice doesn't necessarily require a
character to have been fully and truly
awful young doing guardians of the
galaxy isn't a good guy but he's far
from the worst so why does he have to
die to be redeemed well in his case it's
because his primary motivators up to
this point have all been self-serving so
the extreme opposite of that is to have
him do what appears to be the most
selfless thing possible knowingly die so
someone else can live along those same
lines is the grandmother from dante's
peak and yes i know nobody younger than
me remembers this movie at all but once
i realized that this actually fit i
couldn't get it out of my head so we're
just gonna go through it super super
quick
dante's peak is a volcano disaster movie
and in it there's this stubborn old
woman who refuses to leave her house
despite it being in the danger zone
highway to the danger zone so our heroes
go up to try and retrieve her and
ultimately they all end up in this boat
on a lake trying to get away but the
lake has turned acidic from the volcanic
activity which is actually a real thing
which is kind of crazy but now the acid
water is eating through the boat and the
motor's dead so ruth that's the
grandmother isn't some kind of murderer
or deeply terrible person and she
certainly hasn't committed some kind of
crime that she needs to die in order to
atone for
but
her selfish stubbornness is the reason
any of them are in this situation at all
so it's still a redemption when she
jumps into the water and pulls the boat
to shore
and then dies from her burns
now kind of splitting the difference
between i didn't think this would get me
killed and i totally know this is going
to get me killed is what i tend to think
of as the hyper focus heroic turn this
is where it's actually not entirely
clear if the character knows this will
get them killed because
clearly in the moment they're just
focused on doing the good thing and may
well not have had the time to think
through the possible consequences or
maybe they've accepted it as a
possibility just not a certainty a
character like red from war for the
planet of the apes fits this mold
arguably darth vader does as well
though he might also be a willing
sacrifice since he does seem to take
time to consider what he's doing but
in the end all we have is an
expressionless mask so it's actually
pretty interpretable for the audience to
decide if he thought this was going to
get him killed or not
now this is the part where i'm gonna
have to show my hand a little bit and
say that i personally am not the biggest
fan of this trope now like any trope
there are certain instances that work it
wouldn't have been prevalent enough to
really become a staple of storytelling
if there weren't instances that worked
but i i've got a few reasons for not
liking this firstly
i think it's kind of the easy route
that's not my only issue we'll get to
the other one later but killing off a
character makes things a lot easier and
just a lot cleaner for the storyteller
because
well it's one less thing for them to
have to worry about actually it's a lot
less things to have to worry about if
you're keeping a round or a form villain
there is a lot of stuff you're gonna
have to account for you have to figure
out if the heroes are going to be able
to accept them and forgive them if the
character is likely to relapse into
their villainy what will it take for the
audience to believe the change of heart
is something that's actually gonna stick
there's a lot to keep on top of by
contrast if you kill the character off
the audience only has to buy that one
instance of good behavior keep them
around and the question of but are they
really a good guy now is going to keep
popping up every single time they're
around
and managing that is a lot more work but
there's also sometimes a more practical
matter you may have noticed that nearly
all the examples i've cited so far have
been from movies and barely anything
from tv
and that's because redeeming a character
by means other than death isn't just
more work it takes more
time and to be blunt about it
movies don't usually have the time to do
this
these kinds of heel face turns usually
happen in or around the climax so like
the last 20 minutes of a two-hour movie
and after that there's not going to be
enough time to assure the audience of
the legitimacy of that redemption
so
death is the obvious solution since it
means it's basically a closed question
even if audience is a little bit divided
on whether they buy that this is fully
redeeming or not it's at this point just
an academic debate because it doesn't
impact the actual story while
everything's getting wrapped up because
the character in question isn't around
anymore that's not to say that there
aren't redemption stories in movies that
do take their time but the thing is
those are generally redemptions for
morally compromised heroes
not villains so you can take something
like the unforgiven or in bruges these
are definitely redemption stories but
the things the characters are trying to
redeem themselves for are a background
feature it's something that happened in
the past and if it's shown at all it's
in a flashback so that the focus can be
on the redemption for the bulk of the
movie again taking the time needed
but that's why this is a treatment
generally afforded to heroes or
anti-heroes
you have to go to long-form formats like
tv and that is where you get stories
that put in the work to redeem actual
villains through means other than death
we're talking about characters like
prince zuko from avatar the last
airbender who undergoes a super slow
redemption over the course of the latter
two seasons of the show a big chunk of
stranger things seasons two is spent
reinventing steve harrington the generic
high school jerk from the first season
the third season of infinity train is
largely a slow process of
self-realization and then redemption for
the character of grace jamie lannister
is a hell of a redemption arc in game of
thrones
up until that last season anyway but
like that thing did everybody dirty but
my own personal favorite here is catra
from shira and the princesses of power
catra was a wonderfully complex villain
working for the big bad but driven by
her own personal agenda and
massive amounts of baggage and trauma
now in the third season she went so far
as to try and end the god damn world
just despite her best frenemy and future
love interest adora now by the end of
season four it was clear that catra was
reeling from everything that had gone on
up to that point but she couldn't seem
to break from her most destructive
behavior
it's you
you drive them away wildcat and prior to
the release of season five the last
season of the show
i was
incredibly nervous i actually made a
whole video at the time expressing my
suspicion that the show was going to try
and redeem catra and ultimately pair her
off with adora and
i had a lot of apprehension about that
idea because since i like
most people watching it suspected the
two were going to end up together at the
end i figured redemption through death
was off the table which
i mean it's
good because i don't like that anyway
but i just couldn't see how the show was
going to be able to have that kind of
ending for a character
this dangerous and this toxic who'd done
this much damage to virtually everybody
around her
well the show writers are clearly
smarter than me because they did make it
work
three episodes into the fifth season
catra tries to actually do the heroic
sacrifice
i want to do that one good thing in my
life she betrays horde prime to help
glimmer escape his ship and she's
clearly shocked when two episodes later
adoring companies show up to rescue her
catra tried to take the easy way out do
one good thing
and then be gone
but neither the show nor the characters
we're going to let it go down like that
and her entire arc for the next eight
episodes
is about her working actively on getting
better and it's
really well done because it includes
brief relapses in behavior and catra's
growing self-awareness of her own issues
and open acknowledgement that getting
better about them is going to take time
and be a long-term process i'm sorry i
got angry it's something i'm working on
oh
you are yes now can you please
yes i am it doesn't cheap out and
pretend that the attempted sacrifice
thing means oh she's good now no she's
got a lot of work to do and has to want
to do it and the show
gets
that
gets it with catra anyway unfortunately
given that i'm talking about redemption
in general i would kind of be remiss not
to acknowledge that the show drops the
ball with hordak who doesn't really look
like he's gonna face justice for
anything he does
so are we all just like okay with this
quit side tangent about that whole thing
the fact that hordak getting let off the
hook ended up rubbing so many people the
wrong way kind of illustrates what a
fine line return of the jedi was able to
walk because part of the reason that one
works is that it's focused on redeeming
vader in the eyes of luke and luke alone
luke is the reason he turns luke is the
only one who witnesses it luke was
really the only one invested in vader's
redemption at all
so showing vader redeemed in his son's
eyes is what was needed
but the hordak thing shows
what would happen
if vader had lived because shira tried
to redeem hordak through entrapta and
also have him live
but literally nobody else has a reason
to want redemption for hordak plus
entrapta doesn't have the same moral
compass as the rest of the group anyway
so it's just
weird
like in a bad way
[Music]
now i mentioned earlier that i had
another reason for not liking redemption
equals death other than just feeling
that it's the cheap and easy way out and
this one is going to get a bit more
philosophical and dig into more
moral societal standards and
expectations
before i get into this
i don't think that anything i'm about to
talk about is the intended message of
redemption through death stories
i always say
that you don't have to do it on purpose
because the pattern is the problem and
the patterns and stories and the things
that repeat can cause some troubling
framing for how we view and think about
things
so my gut level problem with redemption
through death
is that it creates a scenario where
someone who has done
awful things
can be redeemed through
one good act of sufficient size
in narrative it's a single act because
well they're dead now so they can't do
anything else after that anyway but
extrapolating from that to real world
application i have major issues with
this very concept because you know most
people aren't going to be part of a plan
that will open a hell portal to a demon
dimension but we all do things that hurt
other people at some points in our lives
and the perpetuation of redemption
through death
paints a world where your sins can be
forgiven
by a counter balancing act
it makes
morals a transactional thing
where a bad thing can be paid for by a
good thing
coming back to earlier where i said a
common reason for this trope is because
the bad things that the characters did
were so bad they can't be repaid any
other way and don't get me wrong i'm not
saying you shouldn't try to correct
damage or that people aren't deserving
of a second chance or whatever but you
have to go into doing that knowing that
you are not owed forgiveness and you
have to do it because it's the right
thing to do not because you think it'll
wipe your slate clean
my big problem with this transactional
moral framework
is that the people it empowers are the
people who are doing the damage
it creates a situation where somebody
who's hurt you
says sorry or brings flowers or whatever
and is expected to just think
everything's fine
the death's been paid it's transactional
and it also pressures the person who was
hurt or wronged to forgive them
how many times have you found yourself
in a situation where you feel pressure
to forgive someone who you just can't
even if it's just not right now
maybe you're feeling direct pressure
from that person or other people around
you or maybe just the general societal
pressure because well
they did a nice thing to make up for it
so
it's supposed to be okay now
this is essentially the same core
problem that i have with the whole idea
of well
you have to forgive family because their
family because it puts the burden on the
injured
to forgive
and perpetuates the idea that
forgiveness is owed and it's
not it's earned and only the people who
were hurt can decide whether redemption
has been achieved or is even possible it
is not
up to the person who did the damage and
it's definitely not up to an outside
observer
and it gets worse because if morality is
treated as being transactional that
doesn't actually encourage people to be
good
instead it says that it's perfectly fine
to be bad as long as you balance it out
later it says that it's okay
to break things as long as you donate
enough glue later on
i'm gonna circle back
to shira one more time
talk about the death
of shadow weaver
if you haven't seen the show she's a bit
of a wild card villain one who has her
own agenda and goals she started out in
the employ of hordak but split when it
didn't suit her purposes anymore and
she's just
the absolute worst she's a monster who
continually emotionally abused or
manipulated adora and catra throughout
their entire lives and in the final
episode she goes to save catra the
person she's abused more than any other
and of course
dies in the process on first viewing
this annoyed the hell out of me because
i thought the show tried to redeem one
of the most deplorable villains through
a heroic sacrifice but
on rewatch that's not actually what's
going on
yes catcher tells her not to do it yes
both she and adora cry but i mean it's
their mother figure so awful as she was
this is going to stir up emotions but
the framing
here is
really
important because shadow weaver clearly
intends this to be her redemption
she makes a big show of it even takes
her mask off for the first time in the
entire show in her mind this is her big
hero moment where all is forgiven
hell she actually says
[ __ ] nobody said thank you but what
makes it clear to me that the makers of
the show understood that she was not
actually redeemed was that after this
when adora and catcher move forward the
camera pans back down to shadow weaver's
mask firstly visually the show is
reminding us of the face of the monster
not the face she showed us at the very
end
once in order to gain sympathy and to
cap it all off the music in that moment
isn't triumphant it isn't even mournful
it's this
yeah
they understood that she was not
redeemed by that act even though she
clearly thought she was
so more than anything for me
the thing that really rubs me the wrong
way about redemption through death is
the subtextual message about morality
that the trope sends
the message that it's possible to be
redeemed by a single big act instead of
putting in the long-term work to
actively be better regardless of whether
or not the people you wronged actually
forgive you
real life redemption
has to be about being better in and of
itself not balancing out some kind of
moral ledger
as i said i suspect that these are
unintended messages in nearly all cases
but they're there nonetheless
[Music]
while it is possible to make redemption
through death work more often than not
i find it to be the easy way out for
both the character and the writer and if
not handled
very carefully it risks reinforcing some
frankly harmful ideas about morality
this sort of thing is why trope
dissection and discussion is important
and even if you think i've got my head
completely spun around the wrong way on
this whole idea i hope that you'll take
the time to at least think about the
tropes and others like it and examine it
rather than just make use of it as is or
assume it's fine because everyone does
it because blind recycling perpetuates
the status quo
and doing the work is what matters even
if your conclusion
does not match mine
in any case
thank you very much for listening
i have a patreon and that is how i am
able to pay my bills and keep this
entire operation up and running even if
you are not able to support me there
there's youtube memberships but
regardless i want to hear from you
whatever your thoughts are on what i've
been talking about drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
the like share subscribe help me battle
back the algorithm
the
lovecraftian beast that it is but
i'm not going to put that much pressure
on you
i'm not owed
that kind of assistance it's greatly
appreciated but at the end of the day
you
are the council i'm just running the
meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
look at you
sticking around through the credits i
appreciate that well you know what
you're about to be treated to a whole
ton of names going by on the screen but
there's a few of them that i want to
give special attention to my special
thanks to bookworm jared boyce mj tracy
scrabbit vincent paul bartolucci kalyn
schwartz edelen hannah acker robin moore
ross schultz and shayla gourley if you
want to hear me mispronounce your name
check out the reward tiers on the
patreon but for right now
thanks so much
[Music]
hmm
[Music]